Higher priced medications have been shown to be
associated with stronger placebo effects.
Now, researchers have shown that higher drug prices
are also associated with a stronger nocebo effect.
The placebo effect means you feel positive effects
because you think you are receiving treatment
(when you really aren’t).
The nocebo effect means you feel negative
side effects
because you think you are receiving treatment
(when you really aren’t).
Basically, this new study shows
that if you think a drug costs more,
you might experience stronger negative side effects.
To figure this out, the researchers designed two boxes,
one blue and one orange.
They then asked subjects to rate how expensive
they thought a medicinal cream would be if
it came in the box.
The blue design was rated as
significantly more expensive.
Then, another set of subjects were told
the cream in these boxes was designed to reduce
itchiness and that as a side effect the cream
would increase pain sensitivity.
The researchers told participants in advance
that the cream was expensive or not,
showed them the box,
and then had them apply it.
Then, they exposed their arms
to a slightly painful heat stimuli.
People that thought they had gotten the more
expensive cream reported more pain with the
same heat when compared with those
on the cheaper-seeming cream.
The researchers think this happens because of
the perception that more expensive drugs
are more powerful
and would therefore have stronger side-effects.
fMRI images of the brains and upper spinal cords
of subjects showed that the increased nocebo effect
was correlated with more activity
in the prefrontal cortex.
Understanding the top-down
and bottom-up processing of pain in the body
may one day help to treat chronic pain.
And understanding how nocebo
and placebo effects are increased,
can help researchers design better drug trials.